I know you're not feeling well but I
wanted to share some exciting news with
you I'm pregnant grandma Katy Perry's
bittersweet goodbye to her grandma on
Monday Katy shared the sad news that her
ninety nine year old grandmother and
pearl Hudson had died tweeting in part
quote may she rest in deep peace the
singer also took to Instagram to share a
series of pics and videos of her grandma
including this one with former President
Barack Obama and this one with Katy's
fiance Orlando Bloom grandma do you have
anything to say to my new boyfriend ya
know just make sure you walk the white
chalk line but perhaps the sweetest
moment is this grandma Katy I just
wanted to tell you I know you're not
feeling well but I wanted to share some
exciting news with you you remember me
lady
we're gonna tell you that I'm gonna have
a baby I'm pregnant grandma that's Katie
sitting by her grandma's hospital bed
telling her the happy news that she's
expecting her first baby with Orlando
katie is finally pregnant she's last one
but I have a baby inside me and I wanted
to tell that to you don't say and while
you can't see an Pearl's face just look
at her arm move with excitement by the
news along with the pics and video
Katie shared a lengthy written tribute
to her grandma calling her a fighter
adding a lot of what I am is because of
my father and he is because of her she
ended her post saying that her unborn
baby gained an angel to look over them
[Music]
the 35 year old mama-to-be first
announced her pregnancy news in the
music video for her new single never
worn white after the video premiered
Katy answered all of her fans burning
questions on Instagram I am excited
we're excited and happy and it's
probably the longest secret I've ever
had to keep and I like to tell you guys
everything but I know I would tell you
in the best way which is through a piece
of music Orlando has a nine-year-old son
Flynn whom he shares with his ex-wife
Miranda Kerr as for Katy being a mom was
always something she wanted do you think
you never have to down the road of
course I think when the time is right I
will probably make my biggest project
my biggest collaboration bus 4 and
that's when I will focus a lot more of
my time over to being a good mother and
giving as much attention as children
need
[Music]